la ministre de la justice nicole
belloubet s'est rendu au commissariat de
trappes dans le quartier des merisiers
zone appartenant au quartier de
reconquête républicaine trap est l'une
des quinze premières villes de ce
dispositif annoncé en septembre 2018 un
travail mené avec les élus la police de
sécurité du quotidien et de l'état le
quartier de reconquête républicaine est
un dispositif qui a pour but de lutter
contre la délinquance et les trafics en
déployant progressivement des moyens de
police supplémentaires
là où il ya eu des renforts dans le
domaine de la police et où il ya un
travail de vraiment d'articulation avec
les procureurs de la république bien
nous arrivons me semble-t-il à apaiser
une situation
la police de trappes a fait part à la
ministre de la justice des dernières
interpellations des 1550 rôle contrôler
ou encore des dernières prises 100 kg 7
de cannabis 2 109 grammes de cocaïne ou
encore la découverte de 14 véhicules
volés ils ont également interpellé la
garde des sceaux sur l'augmentation dès
violences sur les personnes dépositaires
de l'autorité publique supérieure à 20%
notamment la nuit c'est bien cela qui
crée des réactions de la part de
personnes qui refusent cette présence de
l'état républicain
la justice souhaite aussi intervenir
pour prendre en charge les personnes qui
commettent de telles infractions
tout cela doit je l'espère peu à peu
parvenir à créer un véritable climat de
confiance ces dispositifs de quartier de
reconquête républicaine se poursuit
jusqu'à la fin 2020 dans 45 autres
quartiers sélectionnés